what's going on change myself sage my
heart so it doesn't get up by all these
horrible human beings buckle your seat
belts because the brand new promo for
the upcoming season of Keeping Up with
the Kardashians promises to be a wild
ride for some reason things are a little
bit off my life is filled with drama the
preview which dropped Thursday includes
a glimpse at Tru Thompson's lavish first
birthday bash in April and the tense
reunion between her parents Chloe and
Tristan oh my god
Tristan's here ad while Chloe isn't
afraid to let her drama play out for the
cameras
she told ET that she never watches
Keeping Up when it airs what is it like
for you to watch that back to relive
that really tough time that you went
through
I personally don't watch it back because
I just I already know what happens and
it it's just I think a little too toxic
for me to keep reliving stuff like that
so I stay off social I don't I didn't
watch it and it's just a part of our job
that we kind of have to do so we can't
just pick and choose what we want to
show that's not fair and so that's just
what it is we've filmed everything from
deliveries to marriages divorces and our
motto is like we just thought we all
film and we just sit on it you know by
the time editing happens and you know
the show comes out so many different
stories have been made up that other
people kind of made up about our lives
without you know a lot of the truth
being out there I think there's like
something really courageous than that
especially when you see other people or
other family members going through
things and they're so open and honest
the promo also reveals a new health
scare for Kim who can be seen at a
doctor's office getting some tests
fillers in my bones
I probably have a defense staying
positive until we get some results and I
think one of the things that has made
the success of the show is that we are
you know show those vulnerabilities
momager Kris Jenner also weighs in on
one rumor that has stood the test of
time they create a story that I was
sleeping with o.j after 25 years you
think it just wouldn't be I think fans
also get a look at yet another war of
words between the sisters where Courtney
mentions that she'd like to move away
from her fancy crest who is one of the
reality shows executive producers dished
to et about Courtney wanting to leave
the show Kourtney Kardashian said she
would be happy if the cameras went away
she would how do you feel about that
honestly I don't know how they do it
they've lived for over a decade with
cameras following I could not do it no
matter what they were paying them I
couldn't do it so I give them a lot of
credit from those cameras in their lives
all the time
and I love you Courtney and while
Courtney may be feuding with her sisters
she isn't the only one getting into it
just check out this heated scene between
Scott Disick and Chris's longtime
boyfriend Cory gamble as for what else
we can expect here's Chris's message to
the fans every time you guys ask it's
just tune in because you never know
what's gonna happen
you